what I want to do in this video is think
about a concept that we've already
thought about multiple times in the
context of many many videos and this is
the idea of utility utility which is
really just a way of saying how much
benefit how much benefit or satisfaction
or value do you get out of getting a
good or service but the angle that we're
going to take in this video is going to
be slightly different in the past when
we were measuring benefit or value we
either measured in terms of dollars we
said hey the benefit of getting an
incremental Honda Civic was five
thousand dollars and we talked about the
incremental we're talking about up and
we've heard the word many times we were
talking about the marginal benefit or
early on when we talked about the
production possibilities frontier we
weren't we and we talked about the
marginal benefit of another squirrel we
were talking about it in terms of
berries we were talking about in terms
of another good or service what we're
going to do in this video is just think
about it in absolute terms we're just
going to think of some arbitrary way of
measuring utility and then just assign
values to what's the value of getting
one chocolate bar and then what's the
value that we give to the next chocolate
bar and then the chocolate bar after
that and we're going to do the same
things about fruit and from that we're
going to see if we can kind of build up
some of the things that we already know
about demand curves and how things
relate to price and and the price of
other goods and things like that and in
particular we're going to focus on
marginal utility marginal utility
marginal utility so obviously you could
have total utility you could have if I
have four chocolate bars you could say
the total utility I'm getting from all
four of them or you can think about
marginal utility the utility I'm getting
from the next incremental chocolate bar
or the next incremental prompt pound of
fruit and before I move on there's one
thing this is was a point of confusion
for me when I first learned this is okay
I'm using the word marginal utility now
in the past I've used the word marginal
benefit marginal benefit they sound very
similar in fact I even used the word
benefit when I defined the word utility
how are these two things different and
the simple answer is conceptually they
aren't conceptually they are the exact
same thing the difference is is how the
words tend to be used in the context of
a traditional microeconomics class so
when people talk about utility they tend
to measure it in terms of some type of
absolute measure that they just came up
with some type of you could view them as
utility units some type of satisfaction
units well when they talk about marginal
benefit they tend to measure it either
in dollars or in terms of some other
goods but I've seen either term used
either way so they really do mean the
exact same thing but in this video we're
going to use the term utility and we're
going to measure it we're going to come
up with a measuring scale and it's a
somewhat arbitrary one and we're going
to use that to come up with some
conclusions about the kind of the basket
of goods someone might purchase
depending on different prices so as you
can imagine I've had I pre wrote these
two things we're going to talk about
chocolate bars and we are going to talk
about fruit so right here this these
little tables here I've shown the
marginal utility of each incremental in
the case of chocolate bars each
incremental bar and in the case of fruit
each incremental pound of fruit so this
is saying that first chocolate bar
obviously if I have no chocolate bars
I'm getting no utility from chocolate
bars and this is saying that that first
chocolate bar has a marginal utility so
the utility of that that next
incremental one is a hundred
I'm not saying a hundred dollars I'm not
saying it's equivalent to a hundred
pounds of fruit I'm not saying it's
equivalent to 100 berries
I'm just arbitrarily saying it is a
hundred and what matters is not that
this is a hundred or a thousand or a
million what matters is how this
compares to other things so for example
if if I will say this is a hundred and
if I know that I like fruit a pound of
fruit twenty percent more than that
first or if I like an incremental my
first pound of fruit twenty percent more
then I would have to say that the
marginal utility of my first pound of
fruit is a hundred and twenty and this
is what we said right over here and if
another way to think about it is if the
marginal utility of the second chocolate
bar I get because I've already enjoyed a
little bit of chocolate bar and I'm a
little chocolate it out is twenty
percent less than that then if this is a
hundred then this would have to be
eighty I could have set this to be a
thousand and this to be eight hundred
this to be 1200 I could have said this
to be 10 and this to be 8 and this to be
12 what matters is is that they really
just have the same ratios between them
that really do reflect my actual
preferences so let's just think about
this a little bit my first chocolate bar
I'm pretty excited I just call it 100
the next chocolate bar I'm a little bit
less excited about it I've already had
some chocolate my craving has been
satiated to some degree but I still like
chocolate so I'll call that an 80 we
could call it 80 satisfaction units
whatever you want to call it then the
next chocolate bar after this now I'm
starting to get pretty stuffed and I'm
really chocolate it out and so I'm not
getting as much benefit from it and then
finally few give me another chocolate
bars even less and if we were to list a
fifth chocolate bar I might not want it
at all I might you know my marginal
utility might go to zero maybe for that
fifth chocolate bar maybe a six
chocolate bar I don't even I have to
somehow get rid of it somehow cuz I'm so
tired of chocolate bars maybe have a
negative marginal utility and we could
think about the same thing we could
think about the same thing with fruit
the first pound of fruit I'm pretty
excited about fruit I have a fruit
craving I have I like that first pound
of fruit even more than that first
chocolate bar I like 20 percent more so
I get 120 you could call it utility
points or whatever you want to whatever
arbitrary unit you want to call it then
my next pound of fruit once again I'm
having diminishing utility diminishing
benefit as I get more more and more
incremental pounds of fruit now it's
very important to realize these this is
marginal utility not total utility this
is a utility I'm getting from each
incremental pound it's positive so I'm
still enjoying that eat that next
incremental pound I'm just enjoying it a
little bit less than the pound before
and to realize what total utility is if
I were to have two pounds of fruit I
would get 120 I will you have 120 of
utility from that first pound and then I
would have 100 from the second pound and
so you would say I have I got had them I
had a total utility of 220 you could
call them utility units from both pounds
now with just the information that I've
given here there's a few things you
could say you could say well look my
first pound of fruit I enjoy more
slightly 20% more than my first
chocolate bar you could also say that my
second pound of fruit I enjoy it or I
about the same amount of value as my
first chocolate bar you could say that
my second chocolate bar enjoy less than
my first chocolate bar you could even
say 20% less if these numbers are good
but this still doesn't give you a lot of
information about how you would actually
spend your money you might say well
obviously wouldn't you would you want to
just buy fruit over chocolate bars or at
least that first pound of fruit over
that first chocolate bar well you might
but it depends on how much that fruit
actually costs just looking at this
alone we can just make relative
judgments about how much we prefer each
incremental bar or each incremental
pound or them relative to each other but
it really doesn't tell us how we would
spend our actual money so let's think
about things let's put some prices on
some of these goods and think about how
we would actually allocate our dollar
given these marginal utility numbers
right over here so let's say let's say
that let's say that the chocolate bars
are one dollar one dollar per bar and
let's say that the fruit is two dollars
per pound two dollars per pound so this
is going to be per pound this is going
to be per bar and what we're going to
think about is we're going to think
about marginal utility marginal utility
for that incremental chocolate bar per
price of that incremental chocolate bar
and here the price is going to be at $1
per pound so here for that first bar I'm
going to be spending a dollar and I'm
getting 100 marginal utility points
whatever you want to call it so I'm
getting a hundred marginal utility
points for that dollar so I'm getting a
hundred 100 marginal utility points per
dollar here same logic I'm getting 80
marginal utility points per dollar this
is pretty simple math here I'm getting
60 marginal utility points for the
dollar here I'm getting 40 so that
doesn't seem too interesting it might be
a little bit more interesting here what
is the marginal utility per incremental
fruit that I'm getting per dollar per
price or actually per price of the
incremental fruit here well here that
first pound of fruit I'm getting 120
marginal utility points we can call them
but I paid two dollars for it so 120 120
let me write it over here
so for that first incremental fruit the
marginal utility for that first fruit is
120 and the price of that first
pound of fruit is equal to two so I'm
getting 60 marginal utility points per
dollar I'm getting 60 here 100 marginal
utility points but I'm spending $2 so
that's 50 points per dollar this is 25
points per dollar this is 10 points per
dollar now this makes things a little
bit more interesting if I had five
dollars to spend if I had five dollars
to spend how would I how would I want to
spend my $5 well where am I getting the
most what you really just want to think
about where are you getting the most
satisfaction for each dollar where are
you getting the most bang for your buck
so where am I going to spend my first
dollar so dollar one so let's think
about it a little bit my first dollar so
dollar one my first dollar where I'm
going to get the firt the most
satisfaction per dollar well I get the
most satisfaction per dollar right over
here I get a hundred satisfaction units
for a dollar even though I like a pound
of fruit I'm not getting a lot I'm
getting less satisfaction per dollar so
I'm getting less bang for my buck
so my first dollar is going to go right
over there I'm going to buy one candy
bar then where I'm going to spend my
second dollar dollar - so once again I
just want to look at all of my options
and we're going to assume that these are
only the I'm going to spend my $5 on
either these two just to limit our
universe once again I'm going to
maximize my bank for rock I get 80
satisfaction points or marginal utility
points over here per dollar I only get
60 over here so I'm still i'm going to
buy even a second chocolate bar i am
going to buy a second chocolate bar
let's keep going where am I going to
spend my third dollar now it gets a
little bit interesting now it gets a
little bit interesting I could spend my
third dollar right over here and get 60
points per dollar or I could spend it
over here and get 60 points per dollar
we actually get the same amount these
are both 60 points per dollar so I'm
kind of neutral I'm gonna get the same
bang for my buck whether I get another
chocolate bar or whether I get another
fruit so just for simplicity let's say I
get another chocolate bar I could have
got the fruit - these are really it's
really a toss-up I could flip a coin and
I choose to get another chocolate bar so
I first spent my first
three dollars on three chocolate bars
now where am I going to spend my fourth
dollar
well my fourth dollar now my best bang
for my buck isn't to get another
chocolate bar I'm only gonna get 40
units per buck there now it is to spend
it on fruit so now the next dollar I
could spend on half a pound of fruit and
I would get this and then I have so my
fourth dollar I could spend on this for
half a pound of fruit because it's two
dollars per pound and then I could spend
my fifth dollar there too and that so
this is my fourth and my fifth dollar
because it's two dollars you could think
of it that we're spending two dollars
for one pound of fruit and we're getting
sixty utility points per dollar so we're
getting the best bang for our buck right
over there
but what was useful about this is it
allowed us without thinking about money
just saying how much do we like these
things irrespective of their actual
price and then given a certain price it
allowed us to think rationally about
well how would we actually spend our
money in this case when chocolate bars
are a dollar and fruit is two dollars
per pound we decided to buy three
chocolate bars and only one pound of
fruit